nous
bonjour
aujourd'hui on va parler de spinoza on a
eu l'occasion de parler
sur cette chaîne
ray bd ce qu'on a déjà dit sur lui je
vous invite à aller écouter les épisodes
que je lui est consacré
aujourd'hui j'aimerais qu'on s'attarde
sur l'un des concepts que spinoza
utilise un concept assez mal connue et
pourtant fondamentale pour comprendre sa
pensée
or le concept de conatus
or
qu'est ce que le conatus
pour le dire simplement le coup us
or ce qui anime toute chose qui existe
le conatus
c'est l'impulsion intérieur la force
intérieure
il pousse toute chose et tout être
vivant à persévérer dans son être
c'est une expression vous avez peut-être
déjà entendu persévérer dans son être
et c'est vrai que quand on est pas
familier du vocabulaire philosophique
on peut être un peu intimidés par ce
genre d'expressions un peu barbare
mais vous allez voir que ça fait
référence à quelque chose d' extrêmement
concret
quelque chose que nous expérimentons
tous
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'aimerais consacrer cet épisode à
l'étude de cette notion
alors pour expliquer ce qu'est le
conatus
simple est de commencer par parler du
conatus chez les êtres vivants
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que le conatus
était ce qui pousse toute chose à
persévérer dans son être
cela inclut donc à la fois les êtres
animés et les êtres inanimé mais
concrètement c'est beaucoup plus facile
de comprendre ce qu'est le conatus à
partir des êtres vivants
alors prenons le cas la natte rue main
main un être humain vivant c'est un
autre
a le désir de rester vivant
par là
dire qu'en tant qu'être vivant
parce qu'on appelle un instinct de
conservation
un instinct de conservation qui va nous
pousser à tout faire pour rester en vie
c'est cet instant de conservation qui
nous pousse à réagir face à une menace
ce soir par l' attaque ou par la fuite
on pourrait croire que la claque et la
fuite sont de comportements opposés et
pourtant ces deux comportements
obéissent à la même logique
la logique de la conservation
la logique de la survie
quand on réagit à une menace pour
neutraliser cette menace
si vous voyez une araignée sur votre
canapé vous allez vouloir la tuer
même si elle ne vous a rien fait
parce que consciemment ou non vous
l'associez à une menace
donc vous allez la tuer pour ne pas
prendre le risque qu'elles vous mordent
d'ailleurs si les araignées mordent
c'est justement par réflexe défensif
dire parce qu'elles se sentent menacés
c'est la même chose avec les guêpes le
meilleur moyen de se faire piquer par
une guêpe
c'est de vouloir la tuer
parce qu'alors elle va contre attaquer
animaux fonctionne ainsi il attaque pour
ne pas être attaqué
la fuite c'est la stratégie privilégiée
lorsque la menace est jugée trop
importante pour s'y confronter
si vous vous balader en forêt et que
vous tombez sur un ours de deux mètres
cinquante et de 850 kg votre intérêt
vital ce n'est pas de l'affronter
c'est de fuir
donc en général ce qui fait qu'on va
optez pour l'attack ou pour la fuite
dans une stratégie de survie
c'est la force de l'adversaire
plus votre adversaire sera faible
plus vous pourrez vous permettre de
choisir la tac
adversaire sera fort
aura intérêt à opter pour la fuite
le cas extrême étant la catastrophe
naturelle incendie la tornade séisme
ouh là vous n'avez pas d'autre choix que
de fuir
votre adversaire étant pour ainsi dire
hors d'atteinte
donc pas
on dispose c'est qu'est ce qui fait que
nous réagissons ainsi face à une menace
qu'est ce que nous allons recourir à une
stratégie de survie
au lieu de simplement nous laisser tuer
et bien si on va être honnête
la réponse c'est qu'on ne sait pas
quand je dis qu'on ne sait pas qu'on
soit bien clair
réflexe de survie et nous sommes équipés
physiologiquement pour répondre
instantanément à une menace contre notre
vie
c'est qu'on est doté de cet instinct de
survie c'est à dire que ce désir de
persévérer dans l'existence
mais ce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est pourquoi on en est doté
c'est juste
ça
l'instance et ce n'est pas qu'elle 11 on
peut expliquer
expliquer au sens d'en donner la cause
c'est seulement qu'elle chose qu'on peut
constater
et s'il une explication à cet instinct
de conservation
la seule explication qu'on pourrait
donner
et qu'il y en ou un désir de vivre
désir qui est au delà de toute
explication rationnelle
lorsque vous réagissez à une menace
l'animalité qui réagit
ce n'est pas votre conscience
autre instant
et l'instinct ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui a besoin d'être conscient
m opérant
c
quand notre intégrité physique est
menacée
le corps réagit
il réagit tout seul
spontanément
ic
donc tout se passe si les êtres vivants
étaient ainsi dire programmé pour la
survie
lorsque nous rencontrons une menace à
notre vie
notre corps réagit
comme dit camus le corps recule devant
l'anéantissement
ok d'ailleurs que cet instant de
conservation
trouve aussi bien chez les êtres humains
et les animaux que chez les végétaux
certaines plantes sont capables
d'émettre des effluves pour tenir à
distance les insectes prédateurs voir
pour les tuer
il y a un instinct de survie chez les
végétaux comme il y a un instinct de
survie chez les animaux et chez les
êtres humains autrement dit il y a un
instinct de survie chez tous ceux qui
vit
et donc qu'est ce qu'on peut conclure de
tout cela
tout ce qu'on peut en conclure
c'est qu'il y a dans la vie
un sip d'autoconservation
un principe de persévérance dans l'être
autrement dit de tout ce qui est en vie
désire rester en vie
la vie c'est ce qu'ils travaillent à ça
chn
la cendre con
on ne sait qui seulement au travers de
la tacc et de la fuite face à une menace
il ya beaucoup d'autres comportements au
sein du règne du vivant qui témoigne de
ce que schopenhauer rappellerai à
vouloir vivre
et comportements dont nous faisons tous
l'expérience et que nous ne pensons même
pas à rattacher à notre instinct de
survie tellement ils sont intégrés à
notre quotidien
par exemple se nourrir
se nourrir c'est un mode d'expression de
notre vouloir vivre
c'est un mode d'expression de notre
désir de persévérer dans l'être
mangez ce n'est pas seulement une
affaire de plaisir
c'est d'abord
les besoins
si on cesse de s'alimenter ou de
s'hydrater pendant plusieurs jours
on meurt
rires ça fait partie de ce qu'est piqûre
appelait les désirs naturel et
nécessaire
hurel parce qu indépendant de notre
culture
nécessaire parce qu indispensable à
notre survie
donc la fin cette sensation de manque de
sensations de besoins qui nous pousse à
nous nourrir c'est la traduction
physiologique du vouloir vivre
bien d'accord qu'à voir fin ça ne se
contrôle pas
on ne décide pas d'avoir faim
on a faim parce que notre corps nous
signale qu'on a besoin de manger pour se
maintenir en vie
avoir le ventre qui gargouille
voir un message du corps qui nous dit
c'est l'heure
dans des sauces
on a le luxe de pouvoir faire attendre
le ventre
on a le luxe de pouvoir jeûner n'a le
luxe de pouvoir refuser de manger de la
viande
parce qu'on sait que nos besoins sont
assurés
on n'aura pas de fin
eux sont beaucoup moins regardants sur
le contenu de leur assiette
ils font moins les difficiles
donnez à votre chien quelque chose de
comestible il le mangera
takt beaucoup plus direct avec son
instinct de survie
d'ailleurs il a été montré que lorsque
des êtres humains avaient connu la faim
la fin réelle celle qui peut
littéralement nous rendre fous
il développait une cleptomanie
alimentaire
autrement dit un besoin compulsif
incontrôlable de voler de la nourriture
partout il on trouvait
le fait est que même si nous mangeons à
notre faim
notre corps nous rappellent chaque jour
que nous devons l'alimenter pour le
maintenir en vie
un corps qui ne réclame plus à manger
c'est un corps malade
la perte d'appétit c'est le signe que
notre vouloir vivre décline
c'est pourquoi la maigreur ne peut
constituer un canon de beauté que dans
des sociétés où la satisfaction des
besoins alimentaires est assurée
donc pour en revenir aux conatus la fin
c'est un mode d'expression du conatus
parce que c'est un mode d'expression de
l'instinct de survie c'est à dire du
désir de persévérer dans l'existence
mais il n'ya pas que la fin
le désir sexuel aussi c'est un mode
d'expression du conatus
qu'est ce que c'est le désir sexuel
c'est le désir totalement animal
man irrationnel de s'unir charnellement
à un autre être
et la fonction biologique de cette union
c'est la reproduction
on a coutume aujourd'hui de décorréler
l'acte sexuel de la reproduction parce
qu'on a des moyens de contraception
qu'on n'avait pas autrefois et donc on
peut se permettre de n'envisager l'acte
sexuel qu'à travers la dimension du
plaisir et du soulagement
mais fondamentalement
quelle est la fonction de l'acte sexuel
c'est la reproduction
autrement dit
la paix rhdp de choix on ne soit au delà
de soi
c'est inscrit dans le mot
reproduction on se produit à nouveau
c'est à dire on se du blick
dupliquant on revit
rang sans le désir sexuel
sans ce désir de s'accoupler avec
l'autre
l'humanité s'éteindrait en quelques
dizaines d'années
et quel meilleur moyen de nous pousser à
nous à coupler que d'en faire une
activité de plaisir
pourquoi l'orgasme est il l'une
des plus hautes expérience de jouissance
vous ne vous êtes jamais posé la
question
c'est la condition pour que nous ayons
envie de nous reproduire
les ires de l'acte sexuel
la stratégie de la vie pour nous
encourager à la perpétuer
et la meilleure preuve c'est qu'après
l'acte sexuel après l'assouvissement de
la pulsion sexuelle
le désir est en berne
ir n'a plus lieu d'être puisque l'acte a
eu lieu
la vie s'est exprimé rideau
si l'homme n'a lire après l'orgasme ce
qu'on appelle la période réfractaire
ce n'est pas par égoïsme
taux si c'est par égoïsme
c'était aussi par égoïsme qu'il voulait
assouvir ses pulsions
le désir est toujours égoïste
dire qu'ils nous ed quand il s'empare de
nous
et qui nous paraît absurde à la seconde
où il est assouvie
la tragédie du désir
donc à l'échelle de l'individu le désir
sexuel a vécu comme un chemin vers la
jouissance
mais à l'échelle de la vie
et qu'une ruse
la ruse de la vie pour se perpétuer
donc si on regarde les choses sous
l'angle du désir de persévérer dans
l'existence ce qu'on éprouve à travers
la fin et ce qu'on éprouve à travers le
désir sexuel
mentalement c'est la même chose
on manque un manque qui demande à être
satisfaits
sont ce manque va engendrer une
jouissance
une jouissance qui va motiver le passage
à l'acte
et à la fin
c'est la vie qui gagne
sur le plan cabu l'air remarquons une
chose intéressante
qui animent l'être humain spinoza le
nomme appétit
alors en philosophie le mot appétit n'a
pas exactement la même signification que
dans l' usage courant en philosophie
l'appétit c'est la tendance c'est
l'inclination
c'est le penchant intérieur qui nous
pousse à satisfaire un besoin ou un
désir
si au sens philosophique ne se réduit
pas au désir de nourriture même s'il
inclut
le désir de nourriture fait partie de
l'appétit au sens général puisqu'on l'a
vu le désir de nourriture est l'une des
expressions du désir de vivre
mais le désir sexuel aussi fait partie
de l'appétit
puisque le désir sexuel et lui aussi une
modalité du désir de vivre
or on parle bien d'appétit sexuel
comment parle aussi d'appétit de vivre
donc le conatus c'est le désir de vivre
en tant qu ils s'expriment dans des
formes de désir particulière
alors selon les époques le mot conatus a
été traduit de différentes manières
le plus souvent dans la littérature
philosophique on le traduit par le mot
est fort
par exemple dans la troisième partie de
l'éthique spinoza écrit en parlant du
conatus
chose s'efforce autant qu'il est en son
pouvoir de persévérer dans son être
chausse ses forces donc il y a bien une
idée des forts
même avec cette traduction c'est qu'en
français le mot est fort sous-entend
l'idée d'une pénibilité
un effort c'est contraignant
un effort c'est douloureux
or il n'y a pas du tout cette idée de
pénibilité dans le conatus tel que le
définit spinoza
ce que veut dire spinoza c'est que
toutes choses cherche à persévérer dans
son être
chose aspire à persévérer dans son être
une autre
donner au mot conatus c'est le mot force
et là c'est beaucoup plus explicite
parce qu'une force ces neutrons
ce
ce qui agit sur non
j en nous et qui dit de manière ne
dépend pas vraiment de nous
et ça c'est très spinosi
parce que chez spinoza
à cette idée que nous sommes le produit
de ce qui nous affecte
cette idée que ce n'est pas notre
volonté qui agit sur le monde mais que
c'est le monde qui agit sur notre
volonté
spinoza cette phrase il dit l'homme
n'est pas un empire dans un empire
autrement dit l'homme est soumis à un
ensemble de forces
forces s'exercent indifféremment sur les
choses de la nature et sur les hommes
l'homme n'est pas un empire dans un
empire ça veut dire
l'homme ne crée pas son propre système
de détermination
il est partie prenante d'un système de
détermination
d'un jeu de forces et de contres force
fond de lui ce qu'il est
ça que la traduction qui me paraît la
plus appropriée pour rendre compte du
concept de conatus c'est l'impulsion
us c'est une chaud
et ça c'est traduction qui permet de
concilier à la fois l'idée de force de
force au sens physique du terme
l'idée que cette force a une origine
intérieur
le conatus
c'est la force intérieure qui anime
toute chose
on a lu cette phrase de spinoza qui dit
chose s'efforce autant qu'il est dans
son pouvoir de persévérer dans son être
autant qu'il est en son pouvoir
un qu'il ya dans chaque chose un
principe désirant
ce principe désirant spinoza le définit
comme l'essence de l'homme
essence de l'homme pinosa c'est de
désirer
sommes des êtres de désir
et dire que nous sommes des êtres de
désir ce n'est pas seulement dire à la
manière de platon que nous sommes des
êtres de manque
alors oui nous sommes des êtres de
manque
insatisfaction
car on sait que le désir sitôt satisfait
va s'empresser de renaître
une fois la période réfractaire terminée
le désir tel le phénix renaît toujours
de ses cendres
m ce que veut dire spinoza va plus loin
c'est que le désir fait de nous des
êtres de puissance
parce que le désir accroît notre
puissance de maintien dans l'existence
qui en nous poussant à le satisfaire
à agir pour le satisfaire
la fin nous pousse à travailler pour
manger
le désir sexuel nous pousse à séduire
pour nous à coupler
le désir de gloire
ça devrait pour la postérité
que sans désir
non plus
nous n'a compris riom plus
le désir et puissance parce que le désir
nous met en mouvement
alors pour les besoins de l'explication
parler jusqu'à présent que du conatus
chez les êtres vivants
j'ai pris le cas de l'instinct de
conservation parce que c'est le cas le
plus facile à se représenter à l'esprit
mais en réalité ce serait une erreur de
croire que le conatus se limite aux
êtres vivants
spinoza
pas seulement les êtres vivants qui sont
animés par le conatus
c'est toute chose qui est
en philosophie on dira
temps
toute chose qui est est animé par le ce
alors là il va falloir
et un peu parce qu'autant rendre l'idée
que ce qui est en vie c'est force de
persévérer dans son être
couple compliqué de dire qu'un objet
inanimé c'est force de persévérer dans
son être
qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'un objet
c'est force de persévérer dans son être
donc quoi ça veut dire que mon téléphone
persévérer dans son être
mon verre
et dans son être
eh bien oui
tout ce qui est autour vous s'efforcent
de percer dans son être
et la meilleure preuve que je puisse
vous donner est la suivante
qu'est ce qui fait que votre téléphone
ou que votre verre
que tout autre objet inanimé autour de
vous qu'est ce qui fait que l'objet qui
est posé devant vous
se dissout pas dans les airs
qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils ne se
désintègre pas
frère
maintien dans l'existence
réponse le conatus
écoutez bien l'explication suivre
le conatus c'était pas une fois ce que
possèdent les objets et les êtres qui
existe
le conatus
c'est la force qui fait que les objets
et les êtres existe
le conatus c'est la puissance
d'existence
être
ce qui est
pour nous un téléphone posé devant nous
ce n'est pas une puissance d'existence
phone
c'est un objet qui est là parce qu'il
est constitué d'atomes qui se combinent
en molécules
molécule lui confère une solidité
[Musique]
donc a pas à se poser de questions
g existe parce qu'il est fait de
matières points
mais essayons de
la perspective
demandons nous pourquoi la matière se
maintient dans l'existence
la matière semaine dans l'existence ça
veut simplement dire que l'objet reste
là
il continue d'exister à chaque seconde
se décomposent pas ils ne savent les
anti-pacs
de la
porte pour rester là il faut que en lui
un principe de persévérance
un principe physique un principe
chimiques peu importe mais un principe
de persistance dans l'existence
si on y réfléchit
c'est pas évident que les objets zik
doivent se maintenir dans l'existence
donc
ça nous parle parce que notre monde est
ainsi fait que les objets demeure
mais en réalité
il pourrait ne pas demeurer
et d'ailleurs quand je dis que les
objets demeure
pas tout à fait vrai
se décompose
15 dont
l'objet est en face de vous il perd un
peu de sa vigueur à chaque seconde
il se corrompt
c'est ce que disait plaques il disait
que le monde sensible c'est le monde de
la corruption et de la dégradation
permanente
corps matériel s'use dans le temps
et remarquez que c'est exactement ce
qu'il se passe avec le corps humain
il vieillit
prix
il se meurt
donc que veut ir existait
lutter contre l'anéantissement
2 h j esthétique
c'est l'hallu deux lettres main contre
l'eire
la matière
le temps c'est là ce qu'ils cherchent à
détruire la matière
emma sans décor reste là
il plie ellis il s'use mais il se bat
pour se maintenir dans l'existence
et bien la force quelle il persévère
dans l'existence
la force par laquelle il résiste à
l'anéantissement
c'est le conatus
alors oui c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué parce qu'on n'est pas du tout
habitués à voir les choses de cette
manière
on n'est pas habitué à se dire qu'à
chaque seconde mon téléphone ou non vers
où mon canapé persévère dans l'existence
et pourtant c'est ce qu'il se passe
en fait on s'étonnerait c'est les objets
autour de nous sané antilles c'est
alors que ce qui devrait nous étonner
c'est qu'il subsiste
la subsistance des objets maintien des
objets dans l'existence c'est ça qui
devrait nous étonner
parce que si on admet que le temps
détruit tout
alors il faut bien qu'une force à
l'intérieur des choses viennent
s'opposer à la force de destruction du
temps
sept ans
c'est l'expression d'une force
intérieure qui est mise en concurrence
avec les forces extérieures et qui fait
que les choses parviennent tant bien que
mal à se maintenir dans l'être
eh bien le conatus c'est cette force de
persévérance cette force de persistance
dans lettre qui fait que les choses
existent jusqu'à ce que le temps les
emporte
jusqu'à ce que le temps
faux
le connaître c'est l'effort
chose pour persévérer dans l'être
autrement dit
c'est la puissance d'existence qui fait
que les objets et les êtres lutte pour
la conservation contre les forces
hostiles de l'usure et du temps
dans les cours deux filles
vers six thèmes quand un professeur
parle de spinoza et du conatus
toujours un moment où un étudiant lève
la main pour soulevé une objection
personne suicidaire
qu'en est il des personnes qui ne désire
plus persévérer dans l'existence
une dépression sévère ça vous ôte tout
dire de persévérer dans l'être
on ne mange plus on ne parle plus
on ne vit plus
quand une paire n'a plus le désir de
vivre
on dit bien
se laisse mourir
se laisser mourir ça veut bien dire ce
que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que pour se maintenir dans
la vie
voir le désirent
il faut une volonté de vivre
or
et ça ne se décrète pas
on l'a où on l'a pas
or ce pin semble dire que tout être est
animé par le désir de vivre
donc comment analyser le fait que
certaines personnes mettent fin à leurs
jours c'est à dire les prouve plus ce
désir de persévérer dans l'être
c'est une qui
espinosa une réponse
est pour rendre sa réponse il faut
comprendre une autre chose absolument
déterminante
c'est le fait que le conatus
en tant que force du vouloir vivre
chose de fluctuant
deux variables
le conatus n'est pas toujours identique
à lui-même
débat
des variations de citer
le conatus 1 un bloc monolithique
c'est un curseur qui se déplace entre
des niveaux d'intensité
et qu'est ce qui détermine le niveau
d'intensité de notre conatus
spinoza répond
sont nos passions
c'est ce qu'il appelle les affecte
la question
chez spinoza mériterait un épisode à
part entière
mais ici on va se contenter d'un bref
examen
spinoza nous dit
fait qd c'est une modification de notre
état physique et mental
ic et mentale parce que chez spinoza
toute modification du corps va de pair
avec une modification de l'esprit
si vous préférez chez spinoza il n'y a
pas de dualisme
il n'ya pas séparation entre le domaine
du corps et le domaine de l'esprit
parce qu'on appelle un parallélisme
parallélisme corps esprit
donc tout ce qui va affecter et votre
corps une certaine manière
va également affecter votre esprit
et tout ce qui va affecter votre esprit
d'une certaine manière va également
affecter votre corps
je vais prendre un exemple très simple
sport
après une séance de sport
est détendue
et si je vous demande est ce votre corps
qui est détendue ou est-ce votre esprit
vous allez me dire bah les deux
vous allez même trouvé curieux que
j'établis une séparation
ailleurs eq après une séance de sport le
corps produit des endorphines
l'endorphine l'hormone du bien-être
m physique est dû être mental
à contrat la fatigue occasionnée par le
stress par la contrariété par
l'agacement
c'est une fatigue qui va vous procurer
non pas une sensation de bien-être
mais une sensation d'irritation
et vous remarqué que l'irritation c'est
à la fois la colère donc mental mais
c'est aussi l'inflammation
zik
encore une fois corps et esprit
être énervé c'est avoir les nerfs à vif
on pourrait continuer comme pendant
longtemps mais le but c'est simplement
de vous montrer que même dans le langage
de tous les jours on peut repérer des
signes de ce parallélisme corps esprit
c'est ce parallélisme qui fait que même
si vous n'avez pas dormi depuis 24
heures
si vous apprenez que vous avez gagné au
loto
la fatigue elle va s'envoler
la forme mon mental va se convertir en
informations physiques
c'est ça le parallélisme
pour skins aux ars jamais le corps seul
où l'esprit seul qui est affecté
c'est l'unité corps esprit qui est
affecté dans son ensemble
vous vous casser une jambe
ça va vous démoraliser
causes physiques effets psychiques
alami traille la colère envahissant
corps
cause psychique
fait physique
on est dans ce que spinoza appelle les
affects de tristesse
vous prélasser sur un transat au bord de
la mer
votre esprit est détendue
physique effets psychiques
foot
andres que vous attendez un enfant
votre corps exulte
cause psychique effets physiques
on est dans ce que spinoza appelle les
affects de joie
joie et tristesse sont les deux grandes
familles d'affect chez spinoza
il y a les affects de joie et passion
positive
et il y a les affects de tristesse les
passions négatives
août et c'est là qu'il faut être très
attentif
sont joyeuses augmente notre puissance
d'être
elle augmente notre conatus
tandis que les passions tristes diminue
notre puissance d'être
diminue notre conatus
une personne qui n'a plus le goût de
vivre
sun qui ne désirent plus persévérer dans
l'être
personnes dominée par les affects de
tristesse
c'est une personne dont la tristesse
physique et mentale à diminuer la
puissance d'être
et donc à diminuer
le désir de vivre
al'inverse une personnes enthousiastes
une personne qui désire mordre la vie à
pleines dents
c'est une personne dominé par des
affects de joie
personnes dont la joie physique et
mentale à augmenter la puissance d'être
c'est la raison à kehl on entend souvent
dire que l'éthique de spinoza est une
éthique de la puissance
oui
conditions prendre de la puissance chez
spinoza
c'est la puissance liée aux affects de
joie
c'est la puissance des affects entend
qu'ils augmentent ou diminuent notre
conatus c'est à dire en tant qu il
augmente ou diminue notre désir de
persévérer dans l'existence
l'éthique de spinoza est une éthique du
corps et de l'esprit
qui est consciente des répercussions de
nos affects sont votre désir de
persévérer dans l'être
qui est consciente des effets positifs
autant que négatif de nos passions
et qui cherche à privilégier les affects
de joie pour augmenter notre puissance
d'être
je cite
toute chose
autant qu'il est en son pouvoir de
persévérer dans son être l'effort par
lequel toute chose c'est force de
persévérer dans son être n'est rien
d'autre que les sens actuel de cette
chose cet effort en tant qu il a rapport
à la mpt seul s'appelle volonté mais
lorsqu'il a rapport en même temps à
l'âme et au corps il se nomme appétit
l'appétit par conséquent ce n'est pas
autre chose que l'essence même de
l'homme de la nature de laquelle les
choses qui servent à sa propre
conservation résulte nécessairement et
par conséquent ces mêmes choses l'homme
est déterminé à les accomplir en outre
entre l'appétit et le désir il n'existe
aucune différence sauf que le désir
s'applique la plupart du temps aux
hommes lorsqu'ils ont conscience de leur
appétit et par suite le désire peut être
ainsi défini le désir est un appétit
dont on a conscience il est donc
constant en vertu des théorèmes qui
précède que nous ne nous efforçons pas
de faire une chose que nous ne voulons
pas une chose que nous n'avons non plus
l'appétit ni le désir de quelque chose
parce que nous jugeons que cette chose
est bonne mais qu'au contraire nous
jugeons qu'une chose est bonne parce que
nous nous efforçons vers elle que nous
la voulons que nous en avons l'appétit
et le désir
là je c'est ce qui nous rend actif dans
l'existence
la tristesse c'est ce qui nous rend
passif
l'existence
c'est la raison quel spinoza ne pense
pas la question de l'existence humaine
sous l'angle des grands principes moraux
sous l'angle du devoir ou de la vertu
l'angle de la puissance
dire que spinoza prône une éthique de la
puissance
c'est dire qu'ils prônent l'augmentation
de notre puissance d'être
et que cette augmentation de notre
puissance d'être
ce par l'installation de notre corps et
de notre esprit
sur de joie
la liberté n'est qu'un vain mot si elle
n'est pas ce nu par la puissance
autrement dit si elle n'est pas soutenue
par le désir de vivre
le sage n'est pas celui qui n'éprouve
plus aucune passion
le sagesse lui
qui dirige ses passions
et qui sait que ce pas les raisonnements
métaphysique qui rendent heureux
man de notre puissance
la puissance de l'esprit qui comprend la
puissance ce du corps qui agit
et on agit conformément à la raison
la ligne en notre volonté sur le monde
tel qu'il est
nous augmentons notre puissance
nous accédons
à la joie
nous goûtons à l'éternité
je vous remercie
[Musique]